terry is with us in massachusetts hi
Terry welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
Gabe thank you for taking my call sure
so my husband and I forgive me LS pretty
nervous right now my husband and I are
raising our granddaughter she's 10 years
old
we're both in our mid 50s she receives
about four hundred and about $500 a
month for our Social Security type of
thing and other just putting it sort of
in a bank account not really making much
money on it whatsoever and I owe $30,000
on a 401 k loan that we took out a few
years ago and I was just wondering your
thoughts on if I take her money to pay
that loan off it is yeah I am legally I
can do that as far as you know what I do
with her money but I just don't know if
that's wise to do or if I should be
putting it aside you know and a mutual
fund for her starting now she heard she
had a parent passed away yes yeah her
father passed away about five years ago
and my daughter her mother isn't fit to
care for her so that's why we have her
I'm so sorry
tough time thank you okay um well as you
said legally you you do not have any
obligation to do anything with this
money except spend it and here's the
thing morally what is your household
income about one hundred and thirty
okay morally you spend more than five
hundred dollars a month on her anyway
right and so if you just put this into
your budget your monthly budget
including whatever you've saved up into
your monthly budget or into your dad
snowball or whatever morally it's fine
because the purpose of the money is to
make sure the child is taken care of and
you're spending more than that owner I
mean Tom we factor in you know the
the food bill but just clothing in
medical care and electricity and housing
and transportation and whatever else
it's easily more than $500 a month right
so um this is this doesn't even cover
your cost of raising her and so it's
just it's just reimbursing you for what
you're spending is all it is morally and
legally that that's certainly true I
mean legally you can do with it whatever
you want so I don't separate child
support and I don't separate social
security given to minor children from
the budget for that reason because
neither one of them are never enough to
cover the cost of raising the child and
so that the parent that is receipt are
the the caregiver that is receiving that
money is always spending more than that
so I just always put it in the budget as
a form one more form of income for our
household now that means that that
savings account you can do whatever you
want to with it how much is in the
savings account well right now there's
about 11,000 in our savings account but
I had opened a CD when the rates are a
little bit better about two and a half
percent that that is about 10,000 and
that as well and that will mature up in
June so I will have access to that and
you have access to it now because your
penalty would be they would take a
portion of almost nothing which is what
they're paying you it's just
oh so you know you think about I mean
what they pay you and they take a piece
of it whatever it's not a big deal it's
a lot less a lot more than credit card
debt credit card that's more expensive
so do you have any money saved yourself
other than those two figures um we have
about 10 grand shaved-ice I'm going to
scrape all this together and knock the
401k loan out we could let's do it and
we could let's do it if you're gonna
work our plan and be on a budget and
work your debt snowball let's do that
and get rid of is that your only debt
other than your house it actually is the
only debt to thanks out so okay so that
that debt goes away and then that
changes our budget and we have the $500
still coming in
and that changes our budget and we're
going to you know run a budget that
includes saving for college it includes
you saving for retirement includes you
building an emergency fund and doing all
the baby steps that we talked about and
that's exactly how I do it thank you for
taking care of your baby